hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing exactly why
Professor Albus Dumbledore arguably the
greatest Headmaster Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry has ever seen
never assumed a much greater leadership
role within the Wizarding World as the
British Minister for magic as far as
legendary Wizards go in the World of
Harry Potter professor Albus Dumbledore
certainly tops the list especially when
considering the number of legendary
witches and wizards who have wielded the
power for good and not evil for starters
is likely only one of a few Wizards in
all of history who was essential in the
downfall of not one but two dark and
Powerful Wizards both of whom were
leading deadly Wizarding conflicts his
first conquest of good over evil came
when he defeated the dark wizard gelat
Grindelwald on the 2nd of November in
1945. in doing so Dumbledore not only
stopped to Grindelwald from continuing
to gain power with the intention of
subjugating Muggles around the world he
also effectively entered the global
Wizarding war that had erupted thanks to
grindelwald's prejudiced views then in
the 1990s Dumbledore was also
responsible for identifying the weakness
of Voldemort namely his multiple
horcruxes which eventually led to Harry
Potter's ability to defeat the dark lord
while not many witches or Wizards can
attest to attaining the same or similar
achievements Dumbledore defeated those
dark Wizards while also teaching before
Albus was an accomplished professor at
Hogwarts for years before finally
becoming one of the school's most
admired Headmasters so when taking all
of Albus Dumbledore's accolades into
consideration as well as his propensity
for what is just and right it seems
rather odd that a wizard is powerful and
good as Dumbledore and who could clearly
lead an organized establishment was
never the head of the magical governing
body of Britain the ministry of man Jake
what is a minister for magic for those
of you who may not know the minister for
magic is the highest ranking official in
the ministry of Magic the governing body
of The Wizarding World in Britain their
role is to regulate and enforce laws for
the magical Community while also
ensuring that the existence of The
Wizarding World is kept secret from
Muggles but being the minister is not
all Wonder waving in incantations it
comes with great responsibility they
have to act as an intermediary between
the Wizarding World and the Mughal
government and manage the various
departments and employees of the
ministry being Minister means making
crucial decisions that affect the entire
Wizarding community and sometimes even
the fate of the entire magical world
it's a weighty burden to bear especially
when dark Wizards like Grindelwald and
Voldemort threaten the very foundations
of The Wizarding Society
to succeed as Minister for magic one
must possess Not Only Magical prowess
but also strong leadership skills a
great Minister needs to be knowledgeable
adaptable and possess the courage to
make tough choices but let's not forget
that the minister is also a
representative of the Wizarding
Community acting as a voice for the
people they must listen and address the
concerns of their constituents ensuring
that their rights and safety are
protected it's a delicate balance
between upholding Law and Order while
preserving the individual freedoms and
values cherished by all witches and
wizards taking on such a responsibility
is no small commitment the British
Ministry of magic had long since Been
Around by the time Albus Dumbledore
could have been the minister with the
institution itself having been formally
established in 1707 and while in the
centuries that followed this position
was typically democratically elected
there have been several occasions in
which the roles appointed to or offered
to a witch or wizard the first instance
in which an appointment was given over
an election was in the case of the first
ever Minister for magic you like Camp
which likely had to do with magical
Society wanting to get the governing
body up and running however appointments
like this did occur several more times
over the years
specifically in times of crisis when it
was more prudent to fill the role
quickly than it was to hold a public
vote in terms of our topic in today's
video as you may have guessed the final
instance that we know of in which the
role of Minister for magic was simply
offered to an individual was when the
ministry asked Albus Dumbledore if he
would like the position an offer which
was made and declined by Dumbledore on
multiple occasions why didn't he accept
but why wouldn't Dumbledore have
accepted the offer to become Minister
for magic if not the first time around
perhaps the second or even the third
what made him reject the role again and
again what exactly held him back surely
he knew the type of difference he could
have made had he been in that kind of
position of power imagine how different
the event of the Order of the Phoenix
and the half PUD Prince may have been if
Dumbledore had been Minister for magic
instead of Cornelius fudge or Rufus
scrimja well as the deceased Professor
shared with Harry One the two caught up
in limbo in 1998. he turned down the
position of Minister for magic
repeatedly for one main reason he didn't
trust himself with that much power I
meanwhile was offered the post of
Minister for magic not once but several
times naturally I refused I had learned
that I was not to be trusted with power
but you'd have been better much better
than fire drove scrimger burst out Harry
would I Mar stumbledore heavily I'm not
so sure I'd proven as a very young man
that power was my weakness and my
Temptation it is a Curious Thing Harry
but perhaps those who are best suited to
power are those who have never sought it
those who like you have leadership
thrust upon them and take up the mantle
because they must and find to their own
surprise they wear it well I was safer
at Hogwarts as many of you will recall
the circumstances that Dumbledore is
referring to in this confession to Harry
is that he neglected his
responsibilities as his ailing sister's
Guardian in the pursuit of uniting the
Deathly Hallows alongside Gaelic Grand
world and despite not knowing exactly
what led to Ariana's death he believed
himself accountable and feared that
since he had once been an incredibly
ambitious and prideful young wizard with
dreams of Glory he could never again be
trusted with the prospect of power as
there is no fixed term for a minister
for Magic's time in office I suppose
Dumbledore feared that if given the
power and responsibilities associated
with the role it was highly possible
that he would stumble down a path of no
return becoming a power hungry monster
perhaps he thought that he would become
so egotistical that he would simply
refuse to relinquish his authority and
doom the British Ministry for magic to
be subjected to his Reign but as it
turns out that really wouldn't have been
possible as the ministry is not a
dictatorship and each minister is
required to hold regular elections at
least once every seven years so holding
this position indefinitely especially if
he were to fall back into the ways of
his prejudiced ambitious youth simply
would not have been possible there are
clear checks and balances in place in
order to prevent such a thing from
happening for example during Perseus
Parkinson's time as Minister for magic
between 1726 and 1733 he tried to make
it illegal to marry Muggles and The
Wizarding Community promptly voted him
out as soon as they could there's also
the fact that Dumbledore no longer
seemed to Crave power or at least his
fear of power had substantially subdued
his Ambitions this is the very
he turned down the opportunity to become
the Supreme mugwump leader of the
international Confederation of wizards
in 1932 he rejected the offer despite it
being offered by a Chilean a revered
magical creature known for being able to
look into a person's soul and find out
that individual is pure of heart clearly
the Chillin thought the Dumbledore
wasn't a threat to magical Society in a
position of power not to mention the
fact that the Chillin selected
Dumbledore even though he wasn't even a
candidate during that election in
addition to Dumbledore's fears of power
and Leadership there may have been
another reason that he never accepted
the ministry's offers to become Minister
for Magic the fact that he always had
his own agenda in addition to running
Hogwarts he was also constantly working
out exactly how to take down the
Wizarding worlds to Craters adversaries
of his lifetime Grindelwald and later
Voldemort with Gala Grindelwald
Dumbledore worked with Newt scamander
and a group of witches and wizards to
orchestrate how to defeat the dark
Wizard and then decades later in 1970 he
formed the Order of the Phoenix in order
to combat the evil forces of Lord
Voldemort and his Death Eaters after
Voldemort's first downfall in 1981
Dumbledore continued to plan for what he
believed to be the Dark Lord's
inevitable return mentoring and training
a young Harry Potter from the time the
boy arrived at Hogwarts until
Dumbledore's death in 1997. Albus also
led the Revival of the Order of the
Phoenix in 1995. after Voldemort had
returned and trusting no one completely
Dumbledore alone worked out how
Voldemort had been able to return as
well as how he planned to remain
Immortal upon uncovering how the dark
lord planned to live forever thanks to
his multiple horcruxes Dumbledore then
put together an elaborate plan to
ultimately help Harry take down
Voldemort for good some of this Albus
even supported from Beyond the Grave
like when his sentient had Master
portrait helped Professor Snape by
instructing Severus on how to get the
Sword of Gryffindor to Harry in order to
move his plan forward and as mentioned
earlier in this video Dumbledore even
gave Harry some posthumous advice during
Harry's time in limbo at the
otherworldly version of King's cross
what if Dumbledore accepted what I want
to explore next is what if Dumbledore
took the ministry up on their offer with
Dumbledore's own feelings on the matter
aside how do we feel he would have
handled things differently and how would
this change have impacted the story as
well as the greater Wizarding World the
first thing worth mentioning is that if
Dumbledore had accepted the position as
Minister then Cornelius fudge would have
likely never risen to power they wanted
Dumbledore for minister of course but
he'd never leave Hogwarts so old
Cornelius Fighters got the job bungler
if ever there was one so he Pelt
stumbledore with owls every morning
asking for advice Cornelius fudge the
Menace of magic from 1990 to 1996 is
widely regarded as one of the worst
ministers due to his incompetence and
inability to effectively address the
challenges that face The Wizarding
Community during his tenure some notable
examples include vudge's inadequate
response to Voldemort's Resurrection
fudge refused to believe that Voldemort
was back and actively discouraged anyone
from even mentioning his name insisting
that it was a lie spread by Dumbledore
and Harry Potter his denial of reality
ultimately led to the ministry's
unpreparedness to deal with the death
eater's attacks vudge's fear clouded his
judgment and his reluctance to address
the truth head-on ultimately led to his
downfall and the undermining of the
ministry's authority as seen with the
widespread loss of faith in the ministry
by the public inability to maintain Law
and Order throughout his tenure vaj's
Ministry faced corruption and
mismanagement he struggled with
balancing the ultimate authority of the
ministry with the rights of the
Wizarding populace leading to
ineffective or downright harmful
policies such as the educational decrees
that granted Dolores Umbridge sweeping
educational Authority lack of leadership
skills when it comes to leadership fudge
leaves much to be desired throughout his
tenure as Minister for magic he
displayed a remarkable lack of vision
courage and decisiveness instead of
taking bold and proactive measures to
address the rising threat of Lord
Voldemort fudge chose to bury his head
in the sand clinging to a facade of
normalcy he was more concerned with
maintaining his own reputation than with
protecting The Wizarding Community
fudge's leadership style was
characterized by indecisiveness and a
constant need for validation he relied
heavily on Dumbledore's advice but was
often reluctant to follow it preferring
to Dan play the seriousness of the
situation rather than confront it head
on this lack of conviction and refusal
to make tough decisions ultimately
weaken the ministry's ability to
effectively counter Voldemort's
influence and protect its citizens
prejudice and bigger tree throughout the
series fudge's favoritism towards pure
blood Wizards is evident pure blood
Supremacy was a prevailing ideology in
The Wizarding community and fudge's
mindset seemed to align with this
discriminatory belief he prioritized the
interests and privileges of purebred
families while neglecting and
marginalizing those from different
backgrounds and blood statuses you are
blinded by the love of the office you
hold Cornelius you place too much
importance and you always have done on
the so-called purity of blood you fail
to recognize that it matters not what
someone is born but what they grow to be
overall Cornelius fudge's tenure as
Minister for magic was marked by
inadequate leadership and an inability
to handle the challenges facing the
Wizarding Community leading to negative
consequences for both the ministry and
the populace it was meant to serve under
Dumbledore's rule I think it's unlikely
that any of these things would have
happened I suppose you could argue that
fudge operated largely on the advice ice
of Dumbledore but in truth fudge never
really listened to him we've all had
those friends who come to us for advice
but never seem to actually follow it and
it turns out that fudge was no different
throughout the books we see fudge
seeking out Dumbledore's Council on
numerous occasions especially in times
of Crisis however despite Dumbledore's
Sage advice and warnings fudge often
chose to ignore it preferring instead to
cling to his own misguided beliefs and
ideals and in a world where fudge's mark
on the ministry is wiped clean replaced
instead with Dumbledore's Reign of Power
I think that things would have been very
different I'm not going to dive too
heavily into the minutia of this topic
but here are some of the larger
takeaways Voldemort's return the big one
if Dumbledore had been Minister he would
have publicized the warnings about
Voldemort's return right from the start
this would have led to better
preparedness in The Wizarding World and
a more proactive approach in combating
the Dark Lord's influence potentially
preventing the gradual takeover of the
Menace history and the subsequent events
in the later books Order of the Phoenix
with Dumbledore as Minister he would
have had more Authority and resources at
his disposal to form a strong and United
Order of the Phoenix this would have
provided a more coordinated resistance
against Voldemort and his Death Eaters
giving Harry and his allies a better
chance in their fight against the dark
Forces blood status equality Dumbledore
known for his belief in equality would
have worked towards dismantling the
pureblood supremacy ideology ingrained
within the Wizarding Community his
leadership might have brought about
measures to promote inclusivity and
equality among Wizards regardless of
their blood status Ministry transparency
Dumbledore's leadership may have
promoted greater transparency within the
ministry reducing corruption and
ensuring accountability this would have
established a stronger trust between the
ministry and The Wizarding community and
prevented unwarranted secrecy and
cover-ups
Harry Potter and the prophecy another
big one without Dumbledore around to
give him guidance would Harry still a
fulfilled civil triloni's prophecy and
defeated Voldemort indeed if Dumbledore
had been Minister for magic instead of
Headmaster at Hogwarts it's possible
that Harry's Journey may have been very
different however it's also possible
that Dumbledore's heightened Authority
may have led to a more structured and
strategic approach to dealing with
Voldemort's threat potentially resulting
in Harry having him all defined and
specific role in defeating him that
being said it's also important to
consider the role of Free Will and
personal agency in Harry's Journey even
if Dumbledore had been guiding Harry
more directly it's likely that Harry's
own choices and actions would still have
played a significant role in defeating
Voldemort in the end it was Harry's own
bravery Ingenuity and willingness to
sacrifice himself that ultimately led to
the destruction of Voldemort's horcruxes
and his eventual defeat as for the
impact on the prophecy Dumbledore's
absences Headmaster may have changed the
circumstances around its interpretation
but it's unlikely that it would have
completely altered its outcome as I
mentioned above in the end Harry's
success was largely due to his own
actions resilience and bravery and his
Destiny is the chosen one was only a
small part of the larger story of his
growth in development as a wizard and a
person and with that last and most
important Point established I'm going to
stop myself with the Dumbledore's
Minister instead of Headmaster there are
almost too many changes to count that's
why I'm gonna ask you guys what do you
think what would have changed in a world
with Dumbledore as Minister would it
have prospered in a way unlike we've
ever seen before or would Dumbledore's
thirst for power re-emerge in the worst
way possible let me know down in the
comments below as always if you enjoyed
this video don't forget to like it and
subscribe to the channel also be sure to
check out the content on Spotify as well
as extra content on my second Channel
Harry Potter Theory extra until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
foreign